[Music]
the incredibly detailed costumes on Game
of Thrones
have won three Emmy Awards over their
past six seasons Michele Clapton and her
team used costumes as a storytelling
device color accessories fabric and cut
reveal character allegiances and
personalities keep watching if you want
to see how the costumes of Daenerys
Targaryen
Tyrion Lannister Cersei Lannister Sansa
Stark and Jon Snow javis all Daenerys
Targaryen has always remained faithful
to her house but has dramatically
changed her style from season one she
starts as a soft-spoken girl in flowing
lilac dresses then she fully accepts the
Dothraki style during her time with Khal
Drogo and her trip over the Dothraki sea
she adapts again to the local style of
car adding her own gold armor she
changes to a blue dress and pants combo
with cap sleeves dragon scales and
dragon inspired jewelry for season 3
once she settled in marine in season 4
we see more variety still blue and
Dragon inspired she takes a liking to
white in season 5 complete with scales
and dragon inspired jewelry in season 6
she shifts to black and both black
Dothraki leather and striking down and
the new promo from season 7
she wears a fur-lined flush dress with a
driving class red cape every inch of
Targaryen dragon tyrion lanister starts
off the series in the reds and goals of
a Lannister lion he remains faithful to
his colors and family duty until he is
accused of killing his nephews he is
spirited away and during his travels
across the Narrow Sea and throughout
Essos he wears in description and creams
one standing names piri in her hand he
adopts the Targaryen black his sister
Cersei starts off on happily married to
Robert Baratheon she's always been a
Lannisters through and through and
depicts this in striking red and gold
and seasons two and three when Joffrey
dies in season four she adopts black in
mourning then she's thrown in the
dungeons of the fake militant and forced
to wear beige rags she returns in black
still mourning and finishes strong with
an armored dress this theme appears to
continue in season 7
Sansa Stark has one of the most diverse
costume evolutions of the entire cast
she starts in stark graves in the
flattering light slew when her father
has killed her Powell becomes muted as
she tries to find help in King's Landing
she believes she will escape to
Highgarden but changes to faded gold and
Red's when she is married to Tyrion
instead and when she escapes to the Vale
dyes her hair black and dresses to match
she keeps the black scene when she
returns to Winterfell to be married
again when she is rescued from Ramsay
Bolton she still wears black but sports
the emblem of the direwolf her costume
in season 7 complements Jon his closer
to beginning iron stark grades and
brownish fur when he joins the Nights
Watch all his clothes are dyed black
which he wears throughout the season
when he is resurrected he claims that
his watch has ended and takes back his
dark heritage he is also revealed to
allegedly be a Targaryen even though he
doesn't know it his costume for season 7
looks almost identical to Ned Stark's
from season 1 do you want to know more
about the costume design from the series
what's your favorite look let us know in
the comments below and don't forget to
subscribe